was there anything that you that you
didn't like while you were shooting the
show
the monkey and the monkey remember the
one where marcel the monkey made
multiple appearances on friends
guys there's uh somebody i'd like you to
meet
wait wait what is that that would be
marcel you want to say hi
no no i don't well according to david
schwimmer who played ross geller
marcel was the only castmate he didn't
like
the actor shared his true feelings about
working with the primate during the
friends reunion special which
dropped on hbo max on thursday was there
anything
that you that you didn't like while you
were shooting the show the monkey
and the monkey not myself really
the monkey scared me i loved the monkey
david was not
yeah cause you didn't have to touch it
as for why well
david says the monkey was too difficult
to work with here is my problem like
the the monkey obviously it was trained
and
it had to hit its mark and do its thing
right at the you know
at the perfect time but what inevitably
began to happen was
we would all have choreographed like
bits kind of timed
out and it would get messed up because
the monkey
didn't do its job right so we'd have to
we'd have to we'd have to reset we'd
have to go again because the monkey
didn't get it right
david's so angry still david also
mentioned that in between takes marcel
would stay on his shoulder
at which point the trainer would bring
over some live treats
the trainer would come up and just open
and give give the monkey live grubs
to eat so the monkey the monkey would be
sitting on my shoulder
take some grubs and take some grubs like
break them in half these squirming live
brook they'd eat it
and then he just go like that so
i'd have monkey grubby hands all over
all over and the friend star hilariously
had two words for the monkey
it was time for marcel too
to fall
we really grew close as a family and
part of the reason was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to but that's
not the only thing the cats revealed on
the special
i hadn't seen it really in
17 years until my daughter just started
watching it
this past year and that kind of sucked
me into it
yep friends which lasted for 10 seasons
is so iconic
even their kids watched the show that
thing with the leather pants
oh my god that's still crap that was on
the other day i just happened to be
in the kitchen with marina we were
eating dinner and friends is on and i'm
like oh look at that let's see which one
it is
and it happened to be the one with the
leather pants and i said to my daughter
i said okay
watch this this is funny watch david
it was really really really funny
every little thing like pulling the
pants up and
like slipping and smacking yourself in
the head
and i know you it was all so calculated
nothing happens by accident with you
i've watched you
put things together and it was brilliant
e.t spoke with the stars of friends
ahead of the reunion
and jen revealed why their bond is so
unbreakable
there was something that was laid
down at the very very beginning that
kind of went into our neural pathways
that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
and it was without question there was
never competition there was never
if there was ever a conflict it was
instantly addressed and handled
no eggshells it was just
something we're the most grateful women
that i know who have been able to be a
part of something like this